to bring you a few updates that are
hopefully helpful to all of you in the
79 days since the bill the law was
signed our team has hit the ground
running to get money out the door engage
partners and provide comprehensive
resources to help municipalities unlock
funding opportunities so no community is
left behind to date over 80 billion
dollars has already been allocated and
it's headed out to states territories
and local governments that includes over
50 billion dollars to states for
highways and roads 14 billion for 500
army corps projects over 5 billion for
to states for bridges over 7 billion to
states for water infrastructure 3
billion to repair and rebuild over 3 000
airports 1 billion to support superfund
cleanup to 49 sites and 239 million
import infrastructure development grants
and this is just the beginning and we'll
do our best to provide you all updates
and hear um on the status of these funds
being allocated state local tribal and
territorial governments will receive
over 90 percent of funding from the
bipartisan infrastructure law to rebuild
their communities we mentioned yesterday
or i talked a little bit yesterday about
this large guidebook we had put out to
provide guidance and information to
communities uh to apply for the part of
this that will be through competitive um
awards um
as we did uh with the american rescue
plan we also know that local leaders
have the best sense of where the
communities need funding and the formula
funds in the bipartisan infrastructure
law include flexibility to deal with
unique local and state challenges as
we've also said many times with
flexibility comes a great responsibility
to use funds wisely so to ensure
accountability and transparency mitch
landrieu and the infrastructure team
convened a meeting with inspector
general inspectors generals general from
all agencies with funding from the
infrastructure law to discuss oversight
and transparency he called for each
state to appoint an infrastructure
implementation lead and we are committed
to showing
transparency on how money is allocated
and spent also one other update for all
of you at the top as you know the
president is headed to new york city on
thursday and i want to give you a quick
preview of of his trip
he will be joined on the trip by
attorney general garland to talk about
the steps the administration has taken
so far to reduce gun crime and how we
can be a strong partner for new york
city and other cities grappling with
increased gun violence over the past two
years the president and the attorney
general will join with law enforcement
officials alongside elected leaders
including mayor adams governor hochul at
the new york police department
headquarters to discuss the work that
federal state and local law enforcement
officials are doing to quickly take guns
and repeat shooters off of our streets
afterward president biden attorney
general garland mayor adams governor
hochul and other elected leaders will
visit with community violence
intervention leader leaders in queens to
talk about the community-led work to
interrupt gun violence the president
outlined a comprehensive plan last year
to tackle gun crime that includes giving
cities historic funding through the
american rescue plan to put more cops on
the beat and support community violence
intervention programs as well as
initiatives like after-school
programming creating economic
opportunities and reducing recidivism to
address the root causes of gun crime the
president's budget also doubles federal
support for community policing with 300
million dollars more for cities plus
another 200 million dollars for
community violence interventions a total
of a half a billion dollars for these
strategies that are proven to reduce gun
crime he's going to continue to urge
congress to act on that
finally the department of justice
continues to step up their efforts to
combat violent crime and gun trafficking
including through five strike forces
launched last year in new york city and
other regions as the department of
justice reported just last week those
efforts have resulted in thousands of
guns and violent criminals being taken
off the streets over the past year but
they will of course have more to say on
thursday why don't you kick us off it's
been a busy news day so i have a few um
off the top senator manchin just said
that uh bill back better is dead
was the white house aware that he felt
this way and what's the path forward for
some of those democratic priorities well
as you know as a policy we're not going
to get into private conversations we
have with senator manchin or any other
senators about this uh this piece of
legislation or our efforts moving
forward what i will note and where there
is strong support moving forward across
the democratic caucus is on taking steps
to lower costs for child care for health
care for elder care on making sure that
medicare can negotiate the cost of
prescription drugs and ensuring the tax
system is fair whatever you call that
there is strong support for that strong
passion for that a lot of advocacy for
that and there are a lot of members
having continued conversations about it
then russian president vladimir putin
just said today that the u.s is ignoring
its top security demands but that moscow
is still open for more talks
is the u.s open into more talks if not
what is the step forward with uh respect
to russia absolutely we are
the door to diplomacy remains open
we don't know what decision president
putin will make
while we've seen the buildup of troops
on the border uh secretary our secretary
of state tony blinken
just spoke this morning with foreign
minister lavrov
and he reiterated
our commitment and openness to a
diplomatic path forward let me give you
a little bit more of a readout of that
and i can give you more of an update of
some of the other conversations we've
been having
with a range of counterparts as well um
so secretary blinken i know the state
department did a bit of a
background call on this but let me give
you some highlights
the secretary emphasized the us
willingness by lateraling together with
allies and partners to continue a
substantive exchange with russia on
mutual security concerns which we intend
to do in full coordination with our
partners and allies he reiterated the
united states commitment to ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity as
well as the right of all countries to
determine their own foreign policy and
alliances he also urged immediate
russian de-escalation and the withdrawal
of troops and equipment from ukraine's
borders and was clear that further
invasion of ukraine would be met with
swift and severe consequences and urged
russia to pursue a diplomatic path our
national security adviser jake sullivan
also met with his german counterpart
today as part of our regular
consultations with our allies and
partners but certainly the door to
diplomacy remains open as we've said
many times a de-escalation will of
course make that diplomatic path easier
moving forward one more on hhs uh last
week there was a gao report warning that
aggs may not be prepared for a future
pandemic and that it had fallen short in
a number of ways in this pandemic there
have also been reports about uh white
house officials being frustrated with
secretary visaira's leadership so does
the president still have confidence in
secretary vasera and has he talked to
him about any changes he might want to
see at hhs or about his leadership of
the department well you know how we feel
about anonymous sources around here um
uh i would just reiterate that the
president uh remains confident in the
role of secretary pasera he is somebody
who is an important partner he has been
leading a range of efforts from the
department of homeland security um i
mean homeland security the from the the
department of health and human services
um and we have strong partnerships uh
from the very top down with hhs uh we're
less focused on not at all focused i
should say on palace intrigue as much as
we are in vaccinating more americans uh
fighting the omicron surge expanding
testing capacity and getting more
therapeutics out to the american people
and that's how we believe uh we and the
leadership of the cabinet will be judged
go ahead a couple of follow-ups are here
on ukraine
we've seen some of the major european
allies talking directly with putin uh
the mayor macron has spoken with him
twice the italian prime minister spoken
with and boris johnson is now traveling
to ukraine
why not have the president have us you
know take more direct involvement let
some of these other allies are the
president remains certainly open to that
if there's a determination that is a the
appropriate and most constructive step
moving forward um we also have a very uh
active and engaged secretary of state
who has had a number of conversations
with his counterpart including this
morning and that's the channel that
those conversations are happening
through at this point as well as at many
other levels i should say and and on the
question about uh senator manchin he
also said that no one's reached out to
him he hasn't been having talks about
trying to do this in chunks as the
president has suggested maybe the path
forward why not
i'm not going to outline from here
conversations that we are having with a
range of senators and a range of
senators are having with each other but
i can assure you we've been in touch
with and has uh with every member of the
democratic caucus
and uh just some housekeeping on the
supreme court pick uh the times is
reporting that doug jones will be the
sherpa
on the hill can you confirm that and
talk about that decision i don't have
anything to confirm yet uh at this point
about what the team will look like that
we bring in as has been done
historically to help
sherpa through
our nominee
whenever that person is selected i can
reiterate that we intend to have that
team in place before the president makes
this election uh and that team will be
more than one person
thank you jen and thank you for the
welcome back um following up on the
supreme court mr a number of republicans
as you know as you've been asked about
have spoken out about the president's
pledge to pick a black woman for the
high court how do you respond
specifically to ted cruz who overnight
called it offensive
for black women that didn't make that
much well here's what i would say first
just over a year ago the previous
president also promised to select a
woman for the supreme court not only
were there no complaints about choosing
a nominee from a specific demographic
from the same corners but there was
widespread praise of now justice barrett
on those grounds with republican
lawmakers widely highlighting that they
thought this was positive for women in
america so take senator cruz himself he
had no objection to donald trump
promising he'd nominate a woman in 2020
repeat no objection at all in fact he
praised her on these grounds during
praised her on these grounds the nominee
during her confirmation hearing senator
cruz said quote i think you're an
amazing role model for little girls what
advice
would you give little girls uh when
president reagan honored his campaign
pledge to place the first woman on the
court he said it symbolized the unique
american opportunity there is no outcry
around that the president's view is that
after 230 years of the supreme court
being in existence the fact that not a
single black woman has served on the
supreme court is a failure in the
process not a failure or a lack of
qualified uh black women to serve as
supreme court justices
and broadly speaking we just heard from
the president on how he is viewing this
pick he says he's taking the advising
consensual very seriously
um of the senate if he thought and i
know you've been getting questions
around this but just to kind of put a
fine point on it if he thought that a
nominee could get more republican
support how would that weigh
on his decision i talked with him about
this exact question this morning because
i know a lot of you are asking about it
and what he reiterated to me is that his
focus is on picking the person who is
eminently qualified who is
ready to serve and prepared to serve in
a lifetime appointment to the supreme
court not in navigating the legislative
process
just yesterday on a different topic
hbcus a number of them have gotten more
bomb threats today you yesterday said
the bomb threats were disturbing can you
update us on what if any more
information the white house the
president has about these potential
threats and is there a concern that it
is in fact linked to black history month
well we don't have an assessment at this
point we are continuing to evaluate our
um homeland security advisor here in the
white house lisherwood randall is
providing regular updates to senior
staff to the president as well and he
certainly is aware of the latest
instance of bomb threats not just
yesterday but also those this morning
let me just reiterate that we condemn
these disturbing threats and our
thoughts are with the students faculty
and staff of these storied institutions
we have been long supporters uh and have
made historic investments in hbcus and
deeply value the significant role they
continue to play in advancing
opportunity for black students across
america but right now we don't have any
any assessment or new assessment uh
right now
are there any discussions about the
president visiting one of these
hvcus to reaffirm the commitment that
the white house has to the protection
he has certainly visited hbcus in the
past
kristen obviously right now our focus is
on
ensuring we are working in close
coordination with our law enforcement
authorities and ensuring that the
leaders of these institutions and the
students know that we are
watching closely and that we are
standing with them as they face these
threats uh but i don't have any trip uh
to predict at this point in time
please
just one i'll go to you next april let
me just finish kristen really quickly
tomorrow's the one year anniversary of
the family reunification task force as
you know secretary marcus has told nbc
news that the white house is 100
supportive of permanent legal status for
families separated at the border is that
a true statement
we stand by secretary mayorkas
uh go april go ahead and then i'll come
back to you go ahead okay so jen back on
the hbcu bomb threats um there is a
historic issue when it comes to bomb
threats in the black community
and with that said you have people like
lee merrick calling it terrorism and
he's asking for the
doj
homeland security
and u.s attorney's office
to
investigate to form a task force
particularly specifically on
these issues is there talk around the
white house for this to happen
well what i can tell you april is that
we take these threats uh incredibly
seriously uh that again our homeland
security advisor is in close touch with
law enforcement authorities at a federal
and local level and we are assessing
what we think the
origin
the reasoning the motivation behind it
is we don't have an assessment of that
quite yet and i don't want to get ahead
of that process but we absolutely are
behind these hbcus we are uh want to
make very clear that we take these
threats seriously and we deeply value
their contributions but it's important
for for law enforcement authorities and
others to to make an assessment before
we make any determinations about next
steps the white house
see the irony in this moment with these
continued bomb threats of hbcus
particularly as much of the power
structure up and down pennsylvania
avenue are graduates of hbcu starting
with the vice president howard
university um cedric richmond morehouse
joyce baity the head of the cbc um
central state
house with james clover in south
carolina state so
is there irony in this moment
i'm not sure i would call it irony
april but i i would say that it is um it
is it is scary it is horrifying it is um
terrible that these students these
faculty these institutions are feeling
under threat now again we don't know
more details at this point in time and i
don't want to get ahead of law
enforcement authorities but um but
certainly given the history you
referenced um you know this is something
we're very mindful of and that is why
we're so focused on providing regular
updates and seeing what our law
enforcement team assesses lastly on the
policing executive orders um reverend al
sharpton says that there's now a move to
break apart
the george floyd justice and policing
act for stand-alone pieces that could
possibly
go up for a vote and
one way or another pass or fail
and
they're doing that because the executive
orders don't have as much teeth as a law
what do you say to this um effort to
break apart the george foreign justice
and policing act
make each portion a standalone bill
well what i can assess from here april
is whether there'd be support for
getting that across the finish line and
signed into laws you know the president
uh very much wanted to sign the george
floyd justice and policing act into law
and we did not take executive actions
beca at the time
because we wanted to leave room and
space for that process to proceed in a
bipartisan manner so i'd really point
you to
leadership and committee chairs in
congress to see what is possible on that
front and certainly we agree a law is
more permanent than executive orders
that is absolutely true
but we have not even finalized nor do i
have a preview of exactly when it would
be a police a police reform executive
order so i would also encourage people
to wait to assess what that looks like
go ahead thank you jen back to the
supreme court i know the president said
he wanted to seek the advice of the
senate in addition to consent is there
anything you can share about this
conversation with senators durbin and
grassley and whether he shared his list
of potential candidates with them well i
think they were still meeting when i
came out here or or i had not spoken
with him yet as if it was breaking uh so
i've not gotten a run down from him
quite yet um i i think he wanted to have
an open and engaging conversation with
them in terms of what specific
information he shared i think it was
more of him looking to listen to them
and hear what they had to say about
their range of names a range of
candidates out there but also a look to
them for their advice and their counsel
as we've noted before
senator durbin has been through seven
confirmation hearings for supreme court
justices senator grassley is certainly a
veteran of these committee processes the
president takes his role seriously and
as he said today and as you referenced
takes the role of consent of the senate
seriously but uh i don't think we're
going to read out too many specifics
other than to say he was looking forward
to having an engaging conversation and
since justice breyer announced his
retirement has the president spoken
personally with any of the candidates
who he might be considering we're not
going to give a process update or
assessment from here um just as a policy
um but i can tell you that what we're
focused on now is obviously the
president is continuing to uh consult
with leadership in congress as evidence
was as was evidenced by this morning
he'll do more of that this week there's
obviously an ongoing process as we look
to name and nominate a supreme court
justice before the end of this month uh
as as is uh you know related to mary's
earlier question we'll also be
announcing soon a team that we will be
bringing in from the outside so there
are a number of steps that are happening
at the same time but we're not going to
be going to specifics of confirming uh
the internal processes you mentioned
just a bit ago that he is looking
forward to someone who obviously served
for a lifetime um will age be a factor
as he considers who to nominate so
whoever it is can have a longer imprint
on the court
i'm just not going to get into more
specifics of what he's looking for i
mean i think the president outlined
when he spoke earlier that he's looking
for somebody who's qualified who's
eminently qualified who's prepared to
serve in this role there's a range of
candidates he's been reviewing bios of
for
some time now uh but beyond that i'll
let him speak to more specifics thank
you i have one more question on russia
how soon
could the u.s
move troops to
the eastern flank and just to clarify
when the president said it will happen
in the near term did he mean
troops that are already stationed in
europe or would some of those troops
be the ones based here at home
well i think we've said previously that
there's nato troops of course there's 8
500 of them that we've committed to the
nato
the nato uh effort um that would be a
decision made by the alliance some of
those troops are in the united states
some are in europe um i don't have
anything to preview for you in terms of
any additional troops obviously there
are troops currently that are stationed
in eastern european countries
some of those troops of course are not
many of them are not under the nato
alliance but i don't have anything to
predict for you at this point in time go
ahead
thanks john a couple quick ones from
supreme court first um
last week i know you said you'd look for
an answer on whether you thought the
vice president could break a tie on the
supreme court vote have you guys come to
a determination on that
so the vice president has been the
tie-breaking vote for a number of
judicial appointments or nominees in the
past
but our intention is of course to get
broad support for an eminently qualified
nominee um in the oval the president
evoked the ninth amendment as he was
talking about the qualifications he's
looking for for a judicial nominee in
the past and committee hearings he's
certainly brought that amendment up in
the context of abortion rights is it a
fair reading that that is what he was
specifically saying that he was looking
for uh from a candidate here
i'm just not gonna
give any more uh detail on uh any uh
qualifications he's looking for at this
point in time i'm sure we'll have more
conversations about that in the days
ahead
there was a kind of long new yorker
story over the weekend um in which a
former nsca
andrea flores made two claims one was
that susan rice and ron klein had
opposed
expanding asylum access for political
reasons and that the white house
partially because of that wasn't doing
contingency planning for the lifting of
a title 42 whenever we get to that point
in the pandemic
um
and i hadn't kind of built out capacity
to do that so i was wondering if you
could kind of respond to i think those
two points that would suggest that
immigration policy has shifted within
the white house from from the campaign
well uh what i can tell you is that um i
i did not work with uh andrea flores um
so i don't know her well nor can i speak
to her role here but um that our policy
as an administration has been entirely
consistent with what the president
committed to on the campaign and his
effort has been to build a fair humane
and lawful immigration system and bring
it into the 21st century hence he
obviously proposed
an immigration bill on his first day in
office and beyond that he has
protected
the
public charge rule put together the
family reunification task first research
the central american miners program that
the previous administration ended
extended her newly designed newly
designated temporary protected status
for a number of countries and worked
with dhs to get clear guidance for
internal enforcement it's also true that
we're still in the midst of a pandemic
and that is not something of course as
we've talked about here a bit in the
past that everybody anticipated still
being at at this point in time the cdc
is obviously the determinant of having
title 42
in place and that still is in place
because of the pandemic that we're in
but i would also note that we have and i
think this was noted i believe in the
story but uh that we have also
been very clear about our view on the
mpp program uh and very clear in our
view about the inhumanity of the prior
administration and how they handled
immigration and that we had every
intention of implementing a different
approach one last one there's been a bit
of controversy this week on the other
side of the pond
prime minister johnson
and the actions of him and the staff a
report came out this week um i'm
wondering is the president aware of
what's going on
um is he at all worried that that
political controversy is impacting
his you know the u.s and uk's ability to
sort of press president putin on the
ukraine situation and
you know has he ever been ambushed by a
cake
has the president ever been ambushed by
a cake
not that i'm aware of what his reaction
is sort of to this uh controversy that's
that's been blowing up you know i have
not spoken with him specifically about
the reports in the uk but what i can
tell you is that he is confident in the
important partnership we have with the
united kingdom the role they play as an
important partner and uh making clear to
russia uh the uh unacceptable nature of
the buildup of troops and their
bellicose rhetoric as it relates to
ukraine
and that certainly has not changed
despite cakes in anyone's faces
go ahead
starting quickly just with um ukraine
you you guys keep holding out this
diplomatic path
um for vladimir putin but as he noted
today you've already rejected
uh both of his kind of central demands
so what exactly is this a diplomatic
path to um if you've already rejected
what he's asked for and
can you kind of sympathize with the fact
that he may be feeling like he's strung
along and
and and wants to pursue things on
another another battlefield as an
invading a sovereign country
should be the alternative right
right that we're saying okay well here's
our view we don't know what president
putin is going to do
and it is our responsibility to um
and it's an imperative to
keep the door to diplomacy open
that does not mean that we are going to
[Music]
not stand by our own values which
includes the our belief that uh and the
belief of nato countries that uh that it
should be up to nato members to
determine who is able to join nato and
that the door to that should be open um
so if that is one of their claims we
have reiterated the same thing privately
that we have uh reiterated publicly um
it in our view do we have sympathy i
mean this is you know secretary blinken
has used some of these analogies in the
past but when the fox is screaming from
the top of the hen house that he's
scared of the chickens which is
essentially what they're doing that fear
isn't reported as a statement of fact
and as you watch president putin
screaming about the fear of ukraine and
the ukrainians that should not be
reported as a statement of fact we know
who the fox is in this case we have seen
the buildup of troops at the border we
have seen them move troops to belarus on
another border and our role in the
united states is to work with other
countries around the world to keep that
board door diplomacy open because
certainly all of our preference is to
de-escalate
and to
prevent an invasion from happening but
that is up to president putin to make
that decision
that possible end game here could be
just mutual de-escalation and then and
then live to de-escalation in what
regard mutual the escalation tell me
what you mean by that
i i mean i suppose it's up to you to
define but i mean you guys have asked
for him to move troops back from the
border but here's what i'm getting at we
are defined it's a mistake i would say
to define things by the terms that
president putin is defining things this
is a country and a leader
who has uh
you know used chemical weapons who has
invaded multiple countries in the past
several years
who has taken aggressive steps on the
global stage on many occasions so when
we talk about mutual de-escalation
russia has a hundred thousand troops on
the border they are the aggressor we are
working with nato countries to make sure
they feel secure in this moment
nato is a defensive alliance it is not
the same thing and i think we need to be
careful about comparing them as the same
thing just to switch gears to the
supreme court um you guys obviously have
got this big nomination that you're
working on but there's also huge
existential questions hanging over the
supreme court does the president plan to
decide what he's going to do on supreme
court reform before he makes his
nomination he is reviewing the supreme
court commission report i don't have a
prediction of when he will conclude his
analysis of that asked because the
report includes suggestions about things
like changing the number of people on
the court and you would think he would
want to know who if he's going to
increase the size of the court
who he's going to put on first right i
think trevor's focus right now is on
uh going through a process that takes it
that that values the the the seriousness
of the role he has as president that
cons where he consults as you saw today
with democrats and republicans uh and to
select and nominate an eminently
qualified black woman to serve on the
court that's his focus right now
there's been some ethical questions
about
supreme court justice clarence thomas
his wife is has a number of political
affiliations with groups that file
amicus briefs before the court have
other business before the court um it's
his choice whether or not to recuse
himself from those cases he hasn't does
the president feel that there is an
ethical issue there that he'd like to
see dealt with
i have not uh had a discussion about
that with the president or our council's
office i will see if there's any comment
we have from here or it might be a
department of justice comment i'll get
back to you go ahead how's it going
the center for american progress put out
a memo today focusing on specific
priorities for a more narrow buildback
better bill
but not listed is the extended child's
tax credit um could the white house like
apparently cap support a revised bill
that didn't include the extended child
tax credit well i'm not going to make a
prediction or negotiate from here
obviously the president proposed an
extension of the child tax credit as you
know because it helped cut the child
poverty by 40 percent last year it's
something he would absolutely like to be
extended there is a question here as to
what 50 members of the democratic caucus
will support and they support as we were
talking about a little bit earlier some
big fundamental goals which is important
lowering cost of child care health care
negotiating prescription drugs that's
important but i can't predict for you
here what all 50 of them will support
last week the surgeon general also was
asked on msnbc about joe rogan's vaccine
comments
on spotify and he said that tech
companies have an important role to play
in stopping this information because the
uh they are the predominant places where
misinformation spreads um spotify is
putting out uh advisory warnings on
episodes that have to do with copen19
does the white house and the
administration think this is a
satisfactory step or do you uh do you
think that companies like spotify should
go further than just you know putting a
label on there to say hey go do your own
you know check this out you know there's
more research you can look at you know
scientific research writing coping sure
well last july i i you probably know but
the surgeon general also took the
unprecedented step to issue an advisor
on the risk of misinformation in public
health which is a very significant step
and amid that he talked about the role
social media platforms have so our hope
is that all major tech platforms and all
major news sources for that matter be
responsible and be vigilant to ensure
the american people have access to
accurate information on something as
significant as covid19 that certainly
includes spotify so this disclaimer it's
a positive step but we want every
platform to continue doing more to call
out misinform and miss and
disinformation while also uplifting
accurate information i mean look at the
facts right you are 16 times more likely
to be hospitalized if you're
unvaccinated and 68 times more likely to
die than someone who is boosted if
you're unvaccinated that's pretty
significant and we think that is
something that unquestionably should be
the basis of how people are
communicating about it but ultimately uh
you know our view is it's a it's a it's
a good step it's a positive step but
there's more that can be done and i have
another tech question for you
there have been some recent reports that
the white house is planning to issue a
series of executive actions on
cryptocurrencies in the next few weeks
um can you give a timeline on when those
are coming and uh what actually might be
in those executive actions i i would
have to check with our nec team on that
um and see if that's something that is
coming down the road um but i will check
and see if there's anything to predict
for you go ahead brian
i wanted to first uh follow up on
something you said about the supreme
court process sure he said that
president biden has been looking at bios
for some time now how long has that been
that he's been looking at bio as of
potential candidates since last year
that was something that started in the
in the transition process or no since
last year not during the transition
process and what prompted that for him
to start looking at at bios last year he
takes his role incredibly seriously and
uh we certainly know and he committed of
course uh to the american people he
would uh nominate a black woman a
qualified black woman to serve on the
supreme court and so he's just been
reviewing a range of bios and justice
just breyer notified him on the 27th of
january did he get advance notice before
that
i'm not going to get into any more
details if if justice breyer wants to
get into details about our
communications he can certainly do that
and i have a question on russia as well
um this is the jailed russian dissident
alexis navalny yeah um in an interview
with time magazine said that the u.s is
repeatedly falling into putin's traps
putin
makes escalations like he's doing now
and then seeks concessions
um
i want to quote the volley here where he
says with putin the u.s is acting like a
frightened schoolboy who's been bullied
by an upperclassman
what's president biden's reaction
is he is the u.s reacting like a
frightened schoolboy
well i i would say first that we have
great respect for lexi novellany and the
role he's played in speaking out and
being vocal uh even under duress himself
and that's to be hugely admired uh i
think the the the president's actions
the administration's actions that have
been broadly supported in a bipartisan
manner speak for themselves whether it's
our engagement in leadership on the
global stage having more than 200
engagements leading an effort to have a
unified front and making clear about the
severity of economic consequences there
will be should russia decide to invade
or whether it is making clear that we
are going to continue to stand up for
what is a global value which is the fact
that no country should be able to invade
another country and take their territory
i'll let others define that i don't
think that's a frightened school boy
when the president talks about economic
actions that and economic
consequences for russia if it does
invade why not enact some of those
sanctions now why not an act of economic
consequences now why wait for an
invasion
well we have enacted some sanctions um
but i would say that we think it's an
important point of leverage in the
discussions
go ahead thanks jeff to clarify
something you said earlier about the bbb
talks yeah
you know to the extent that you're going
to tell us about them
you said that you know rest assured the
president uh you said we've been in
touch with every member of the
democratic caucus we've been in time we
in the white house so that's the leg
affairs team mainly
what the leg affairs team and senior
members of the white house we're just
not going to detail more specifics you
can't say if the president has been
involved personally in any of the
conversations the president has talked
to a range of senators he always does
um
on the ukraine russia stuff any plans in
the works for another conversation
between the president and president of
the landscaping
he has talked to him a couple of times
in the last few weeks and we've been in
regular um contact we also are in very
close contact from jake sullivan's level
and secretary blanken's level uh so
certainly it's possible we've been in
regular touch but i don't have any call
to predict at this point you just talked
to him a couple days ago
and one other question today obviously
is the start of black history month the
president issued a couple tweets about
that yeah i wonder um what the
administration the president's response
is to
what has been happening in texas and
other states where a number of books
have been banned by school districts
these are generally books that have
focused on slavery on jim crow on civil
rights even on the obamas
does the white house have a position on
the books that are being banned by these
local school boards
i have not discussed this with the
president but i can tell you that as an
administration we believe in the freedom
of speech and expression and certainly
uh we have never been advocates of
preventing people from understanding and
reading history
to do more to
recognize commemora uh commemorate black
history month this month absolutely let
me see if we can get you some more
details
go ahead
good afternoon a couple of questions for
you back to the supreme court sure
how will the debate over abortion shape
the president's election process
the president is going to select an
eminently qualified black woman to serve
on the court uh someone and he's going
to do that through consulting with a
range of members of congress through
outside experts
and obviously through engagement with
them directly but i don't think i'm
going to give you more specifics from
here that person will that person have
to be pro-abortion i think somebody
asked a similar question i'm not going
to outline litmus tests from here today
the president has said in the past he
does not believe that life begins at
conception when does he believe it
begins
you know the president's position he
believes in a woman's right to choose
and he's spoken he's spoken to this in
the past and i know you asked this every
time you come in here which is you're
you're absolute right but i don't think
i have anything new to reveal for you
the question is when does he believe
likely and essential to the debate over
the question of a baby's viability and
pro-life americans don't you agree
should know where the president stands
in his thinking and it's a fundamental
question the president believes in a
woman's right to choose go ahead i think
we're going to move on unless you have
another question go ahead
go ahead
okay following up on the the question
for on the expanded child tax credit yep
you have said time and again that this
has taken lots of kids and families out
of poverty yeah a tremendous success
yeah
but with that now gone looks like it's
gone dead
inflation creeping up high gas prices
high food prices how quickly are those
same kids and families going to go back
into poverty do fear well how it's
implemented first the president's going
to continue to fight for the child tax
credit uh hit something he very much
believes in i just can't predict what a
package will look like and what there
will be support from 50 senators on
what i can tell you is that as
individuals who are eligible file their
taxes they will get the other half of
the child tax credit benefit from last
year that is not a forever solution but
that is something that many can look
ahead to
the other part of the bill for
president's buildback better agenda
that's important as you're talking about
rising costs for people you know we have
a we have a proposal the president has a
proposal many democrats across the board
support it which is that will lower
costs for americans across the country
and all the issues you talked about
things that really weigh on people's
family budgets whether it's health care
which is a huge uh has a huge impact on
people's uh budgets child care which is
contributing to preventing two million
women from rejoining the workforce
that's the buildback better plan and
that's something that uh we know will
help lower costs for families
have a message for those struggling
families very worried right now not
paying an extra 500 or a thousand a
month or whatever that are saying i
can't afford the groceries i can't
afford the gas this is getting very
stressful a message from the president
to those families the president would
say uh i am here to fight for you and i
that's why i'm going to continue to
fight to
pass legislation that will lower your
costs and that is a top priority for him
go ahead
i want to go back to what you said in
the beginning about the um money that's
going to be flowing down to states and
then there's going to be an appointment
infrastructure
an infrastructure leak can you tell me
more about who is who who's going to be
appointing that person in each state
because there may be concern over states
when you get to like florida where you
have governor desantis saying that the
president is trying to implement
multiplication policy and saying that
there is no um racism within some of the
bills that have been in the past how can
their when you talk about accountability
how is that process going to go and what
information may be accessible to the
public as far as reporting
well we have a huge
several hundred page book that we put
out yesterday about how people can apply
for a range of funding uh and i just
i'll outline for you the money to date
that has been allocated and we have
taken steps and we will continue to to
make sure that is as transparent as
possible now some of these the funding
in this package as i mentioned 90
percent of it will go to local tribal
and territorial governments
so that really gives the opportunity for
a range of leaders to apply for funding
and the book is meant to give them the
information and access they need so they
don't have to hire lobbyists to do that
so that they can do that on their own
and we're doing that in part to ensure
that equity is at the central as central
to how we're implementing this bill
my final question is what do you say
um to many organizations i've talked to
several civil rights organizations
on the process of selecting a vice
president they feel like some of the
desires of the black community have been
put on the back burner so when it comes
to selecting the vice president why is
there no need or no push to speak up the
process the president has said he by i
mean you mean a supreme court justice or
justice i'm sure i'm sorry no it's very
court
why is there no need to speed up that
process
um of selecting a nominee well he's
gonna he's going to name one this month
right name one this month but there has
been a little bit of pushback as far as
comparing the process the timing to amy
comey barrett
um as opposed to what the president is
going to do during this time we've heard
chuck schumer say that but is the does
the president feel the same way as far
as
how long how quickly and expeditiously
he wants to move this process along i
just want to make sure i'm answering
their questions so you were saying
there's unhappiness in the civil rights
community about the pace or are you
talking about the schumer call for the
38 days
well is the president going on board
with that to push to push it that fast
well the president uh takes uh the
decision to select an eminently
qualified uh individual to nominate to
the supreme court very seriously he
wants that to be a thorough process and
he's still doing that expeditiously by
nominating someone this month um and he
wants of course the senate to move
forward expeditiously but we're not
setting uh artificial deadlines beyond
that
go in the back okay we usually have two
more so let me get to them quickly go
ahead
i have a couple of questions on two
different topics russia and then
immigration on russia i know the
president has spoke with the emir of
qatar regarding
the role of that country exporting
natural gas to the european union but is
the u.s considering increasing its role
as a natural gas exporter to the
european union to serve as an
alternative to russian gas
we are having a conversation with not
just countries but also
suppliers about how to help meet uh any
shortage of natural gas uh that would
could come about if uh if there's an
invasion also in russia
since ukraine is not a nato member
according to the north atlantic treaty
nato cannot really respond militarily to
russia
and ukrainian territory um but are u.s
intellectual military actions on the
table to support kiev
you mean sending us troops to ukraine
no
okay no and on the other topic that i
wanted to ask real quick um
this administration is now sending
venezuelan migrants arrested at the u.s
mexico border to colombia under title 42
what agreement has been reached with the
colombian government is it similar to
the mpp
with mexico
well i think what we tried to do from
the beginning is ensure that for
venezuelans who are coming who were
coming from a third country right um
that they were able at some point to
return to that country so in this case
um pursuant to title 42 we began
repatriating venezuelan nationals who
had attempted to unlawfully enter the
united states to colombia where they had
previously resided so it was you know a
place where they had been living before
flights to colombia with venezuela and
nationals who have legal status are
expected to take place on a regular
basis and will be operated by u.s
immigration and customs enforcement of
course that requires agreement with the
government
started and how temporary is that
supposed to be this program well it's
it's just starting now and i can i'm
sure i can get you a timeline of when it
actually started
until when this will be implemented i
don't believe we've set a deadline but i
can i can get that information for you
as well go ahead last one thank you john
uh one on the supreme court and two on
code if you'll indulge me sure
first on the supreme court uh does
president biden have plans to talk to
senator mcconnell mcconnell at all
today this week
i expect he will have many more
consultations with democrats and
republicans
i don't have anything yet for you at
this point but hopefully we'll have more
in the next 24 hours two quick ones on
the pandemic first of all i was
wondering if
um you'd be able to provide an update on
the free mask program that the white
house was doing um
just curious if there's an update on how
many of the
of the hundreds of millions of masks
have been distributed already and also
is there a way for americans to know
you know
if there are masks in their area if
they've been delivered to their area at
pharmacies just you know sort of when
when they know that they can go find
them in their area sure so we just
announced this last week but we've
already um cranked up our shipments
we've shipped 100 million
and 95 max masts so far which is
incredible progress they're available at
thousands of locations around the
country the initial wave of health
centers are for people who are looking
to see if they're available near them is
available on the health resources and
services administration's website
and the program we we're working to
expand it to make it available
across all health centers over the
coming weeks
one from a colleague who couldn't be
here
um at news nation they reported hearing
from people who signed up to receive the
free covent tests uh through the website
the government website um but they had
issues where the either the tests were
shipped to the wrong address or they
never received a confirmation email um
so
what should people do in that case is
there a way for them to
to rectify that does the white house
have like a response team in case
somebody you know never gets a test that
they ordered or anything like that yeah
there's a there's a there's a help
component on the website hopefully it
should be easy for people there's also a
phone number i'm sure we can get that to
you after the briefing as well that
people could call should they have any
uh concerns
i will note that we confirmed last week
that 60 million tests have been had been
ordered as of then i know of an updated
number uh tens of millions of tests have
gone out the door and reached the right
right doors i think that's the vast vast
vast majority that is earlier than
we were scheduled and we're planning to
get those tests out the doors but we can
we can get you the phone number and you
can publicize that in your publication
thanks everyone
can you make sure we all here
sure thank you